what I'm gonna focus on here is you guys
know how proof by mathematical induction
works you know you have to test your
first case you have to assume your it's
it's true for a value like k and then
you have to prove and that's where the
lion's share of the work is so for each
of these a B and C I'm really just going
to focus on the proof step and if you
want to ask me about other bits then
that's totally fine ask me afterwards
okay so here's my test here's my
assumption and here's the proof step so
let's just focus on this guy for a
minute this is where all the action
happens okay
in this case really do you have to think
carefully about index laws right which
is often the case when you've got lots
of powers and exponents flying around in
your inductive hypothesis so here is
what I am trying to prove in here this
is my K plus 1 I've substituted in a
small number of you had issues when you
substituted k plus 1 in and you didn't
get like 3 k plus 3 what do you think is
a common error instead of yeah people
say 3 k plus 1 right because they're
like oh it's 3 you're put in a k there
and you forget that the k plus 1 the
whole things being multiplied by 3 okay
once you know that you've got this liner
you set about to prove it it's fairly
straightforward in terms of saying this
is the left hand side I have a 3 to the
3 K in there and a 2 to the k plus 2
which why do you think I'm looking for
these why these important to me why do
you think I'm trying to separate them
out how look at the previous step in
your working it's in the assumption
right these guys are in the assumption
I'm looking I'm searching for them
somewhere in there so I pull out a
factor of 27 from the 3 cubed and I pull
out a factor of 2 from one of these
pounds that I don't need there ok once
you've done that you can say oh look now
I can group together you know a few of
them too that are in the assumption and
then I've got 25 of them left over there
but because I'm trying to prove that
it's a multiple of 5 a multiple of 25 is
totally ok it's a multiple of 5 so that
guy's sorted and I just have to deal
with this guy so you can see teeny bit
of factorization here you've got 5 times
something minor note just to remind you
all how do I know that this is actually
a whole number
yeah you have to think about so earlier
on you introduced Kay and you introduced
you might have called it a moran or
something like that you introduced those
numbers when you did you had to say they
weren't just anything like if P was like
a fraction like a half that's not a
multiple of five okay so you had to say
something in that P and that's why you
sort of remind in your proof you know
hey I said that K and P were positive
integers so therefore if you multiply or
raise powers or double you'll still end
up with a whole number okay so this is
part a right that was the guts of the
proof let's have a look at Part B here's
puppy so you go ahead you do your test
in the first case and it works out you
do your assumption it is a bit awkward
to write out because quite long but then
you're proof it's really nice because
what you've got is a product that goes
you know all of the terms there your
proof step includes everything in your
assumption which makes you something
very easy to use plus this extra guy
here you see that that's the cape Loess
one component there and over here on the
right hand side this is what happens
when i put k plus 1 into all these spots
again common area to make instead of say
2 k plus 2 what do you think people
write to k plus 1 and then doesn't work
out be like why isn't this happening
okay so there's my proof step I use my
left hand side and immediately oh that
was a bit naughty I left off an
important piece of working immediately
you can use your assumption you don't
need to twist and turn this statement at
all the assumption is just sitting there
so you use it you make your substitution
and then you just have to kind of
algebra your way through it okay so you
combine your fractions you simplify and
there you go okay great question why did
I hardly put it in okay the whole idea
of mathematical induction is that unlike
in every other area of maths where we
kind of say don't assume anything okay
only use the information they've
supplied to you what you're doing is you
your second step is to assume that
something is true and on the basis of
that see if you can then construct a
proof on that foundation okay but then
you can say hey
early on this is like a version of the
assumption the very first value and it
means that if work works for the first
value I could say it works for the next
one the K plus 1 and then the K plus 1
after that etc so that's why the
assumption is important ok and then it
is like I said just algebra from there
and you can inspect it yourself later on
it does simplify out ok
last proof by mathematical induction on
this page the inequalities do tend to be
the ones that give us the most grief
because you have to be a little more
creative with these but you can see
there's a few ways to do this right um
here's the way I've chosen to do it
here's my assumption I've just popped K
in here's what I'm trying to prove my k
plus 1 case so you can see there's k
plus 1 in the power there is k plus 1
being multiplied by 3 which looks like
this now how many of you I can't
remember cuz I have a look but I can't
remember now um how many of you went
from here and considered this guy how
many of you did that anyone okay yeah
cool so you can you can work with this
guy that's fine we're quite good at
proving that things are positive because
for instance if you have a look at this
guy
that's got to be positive it's an
exponential it's growing he's never
gonna drop down no stationary points
anything like that and then you can make
your argument over here that was one way
to prove it and I was totally fine I
decided not to do that I just started
off with the assumptions there and then
I tried to twist and turn that so it
looked like there proves that the K plus
ones there so this is this what can you
see I did from this line to this line
what'd I do to both sides I'm not
supplied by two and the reason why is
because in my prove the thing I'm trying
to prove there's a 2 to the k plus 1 on
the left hand side so I put it there as
well okay you have to be a little bit
cautious in here you see what's
happening this is what I want to be
bigger than what I end up getting is
even bigger than that so you can say
well the thing I've got is bigger than
what you need and so therefore I'm
bigger than that too so you can see my
string of inequalities here right if you
want to be bigger than this and you're
even bigger than that then that's
totally fine you want to prove you're
bigger than 5 and you're proof says all
I'm bigger than 10 then that's good
you are bigger than 5 as well